we're going to begin with this a wild
fires that are raging in California
they've now damaged or destroyed dozens
of homes and other buildings punishing
Santa Ana winds spread flames to
subdivisions in Southern California now
this so called tick fire is burning out
of control near Santa Clarita that's
north of Los Angeles that's just one of
13 active wildfires burning in
California more than 200,000 people in
that state have been evacuated from
their homes Carter Evans is in Santa
Clarita Carter the house right behind
you is burning as we speak this home
right now is fully involved take a look
you can see the fire in the window
upstairs firefighters making entry right
now now this fire had calmed down this
evening
the wind had calmed down and then all of
a sudden right around 1:30 2:00 a.m. the
winds picked back up the fire exploded
again and this is what you get now here
is the main problem right now you see
all these flying embers in the air the
concern these embers could land on
another home and catch it on fire and in
fact that's what's happened right down
the street we also have another home
where firefighters are making entry the
goal right now to try and keep more
homes from catching fire everybody in
this community had to evacuate overnight
the fire fight in the canyons north of
Los Angeles continued into the night as
structures burned forcing evacuations
dozens and dozens of families on this
block here
the fire started just before 3 p.m.
quickly growing into a major threat
gusty winds are blowing these flames
through the canyon you can see this fire
erupting here as it hits heavy brush the
concern are the homes on the other side
of this hill nerve wracking pretty scary
right now when we spoke with Murray Hill
the fire was just 50 yards from her home
she barely had time to get back from
work to rescue her dog and she started
crying really hard oh my god she's at
the house we gotta get her an offshoot
of the same fire shut down a major
freeway destroying at least one home
firefighters were juggling multiple
blazes throughout the day sometimes
their best option was to take a step
back the brush is essentially a lost
cause for us right now we're gonna let
it burn until it starts affecting
people's homes and nothing we're going
to step in statewide utilities cut power
to more than two hundred nine thousand
customers to minimize the fire risk in
Northern California the cause of the
Kinkaid fire which consumed more than
ten thousand acres is still unknown but
PG&E says a high-voltage transmission
tower had not been turned off in the
area and broke near the fires point of
origin the transmission line was not
among the lines we de-energized in
Sonoma County we still at this point do
not know exactly what happened back out
here live we're giving you a look inside
this home firefighters inside on the
first floor on the second floor as we
tilt up you can see this house still
fully involved flames erupting out of
the roof this is a big concern this is
not the only home to virt in this fire
may not be the only home to burn tonight
again all of this took off just a couple
of hours ago firefighters rushing to the
scene people rushing to get out of their
communities and firefighters here trying
to put out these flames Tony just
imagine if that's your house really
incredible pictures there Carter please
stay safe for us thank you very much